[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we asked the experts our
fantastic expert guest this week is a
returning guest to trigonometry the
first returning guest to trigonometry
she's a former advisor to US president
and the founder of H robotics dr. Pippa
Malan grand I got it right yeah yes
welcome back to trigonometry did you say
I guess so I got it wrong I got it all
right
yeah I struggle to be honest but it's so
great to have you back we're really
really pleased you've come back to talk
to us you're one of our absolutely
favorite guests and for anyone who
didn't watch the first interview just
remind everybody who you are what's been
your journey through life kind of you
know how are you where you are yeah well
bottom line is look I'm an economist so
what I try to do is help shape economic
policy by advising governments so I'm
currently a non-executive director of
the British government on the Briggs's
and trade policy issues I try to explain
the economy by writing books and I got a
new book coming out and then I kind of
got tired of just being an economist who
talked about the world economy and
decided to start building it so I have a
robotics company that I co-founded
exactly and that's one of the reasons we
want with there's lots of reasons we
wanted to speak to you because last time
we talked about all kinds of things
there was a particular moment of I think
about 40 minutes in when you just
started talking about technology and
Francis's head just started to explode a
little bit and so did mine and we were
just like we have to come back and talk
about this for a good good portion of
time but before we get to that there is
something that's been going on with
Donald Trump recently that we just
wanted to get your take on yes
what are two things yeah I know
obviously by the time just goes out a
couple of weeks from now he might not be
president anymore right that's the
possibility is he gonna be impeached do
you think is that where this is going
so my dad served for presidents I've
served two presidents I've grown up in
this environment and here's my instinct
neither the Democrats nor the
Republicans want to have their finger
prints on an impeachment because it rips
the nation apart it is so devastating to
the soul of the country leaving aside
how much people might hate the current
president that you can't do it you can't
pull the trigger on that without you
were to go down the drain too and that's
why everybody says let's not do it let's
get the prosecutor to do it
prosecutors are supposed to do this they
love grabbing on to the ankle of a bad
guy and then hauling him down to jails
let him and do the job and that was the
plan but turns out not so easy and we've
seen the molar investigation dragging on
not that many charges brought to be fair
considering how much time and I
personally think the real game in town
is not Muller it's barbara Underwood who
is the state attorney general in New
York and they've been very aggressive
saying they are coming after the Trump
family the Trump companies that matters
because you got to remember in the motor
case really theoretically the president
can pardon everyone including himself so
there's no teeth in it whereas the state
federal level the state level is totally
different from federal and the president
has zero capacity to pardon anyone and
the penalty for a New York State charge
is not federal penitentiary that's a
white collar prison with the golf course
and tennis courts New York State
Penitentiary is almost not survivable
for a white-collar criminal so it's a
complicit I mean it's viewed in
Washington as literally a death sentence
so this is the negotiating point and
that's why I tell everybody watch
Barbara Underwood
by the way I met the guy who wrote house
cards and I said to him I think that
you're toning it down for the audience
and he goes here from Washington DC so
if you would Trump at this point would
you be worried
in terms of he seems untouchable to the
outside eye because everybody else gets
arrested everybody else goes down and he
just carries on regardless he's got a
lot of Teflon factor just like Ronald
Reagan who I work for is a kid right out
of college he also had an incredible
Teflon he also had charm which is absent
in this case but hey you know who knows
what's going on inside of trumps head I
mean we know a little more because bob
woodward's book and he taped everything
I would say this the way to think about
Trump is he's caught he's a property guy
who wants to win the deal and get the
prize so you know I've talked a lot
about his interest in the North Korea
deal it's all about he he may not get
the Nobel but if we get resolution
between North and South Korea the
leaders of those two countries are gonna
get the Nobel and he'll be basking in
the aura of that and for him that's like
totally worth it I think that he's got
all kinds of things like this where he
sees a prize and as long as he gets
those then he feels like whatever you
can do what you like but I'm gonna win
anyway
including yeah I would keep a little eye
on any announcements out of the US Space
Station and NASA that we might even aim
to do a moon shot during the Trump
administration and I know amazing as
that sounds but that would be so up his
alley
to create us and what does he just
announced the space force what is that a
cover story for getting a man back up in
space or a woman maybe this time this is
the kind of thing he's thinking I'm
energy
and it's gonna make history and you can
try to take me down that's the way he
thinks hey you know what I have a car in
space well I think most people would
prefer him to but you know I'm not a big
fan of Donald Trump but I would love for
him to get the Nobel Peace Prize just to
see how badly everyone gets triggered by
this but listen your book is about
leadership the leadership lab what do
you think is kind of happening with
Donald Trump Lisa V this leave
leadership like what's what's happening
there why have we
why has America opted for him and what's
going on there I hope they I just spent
a month in the u.s. different parts of
America and I think I grew up in America
of American what I felt like was oh my
god
Kramer the television show on CNBC and
shark tank that is how Americans speak
to each other
that is normal dialogue now that used to
be just one television program that was
kind of for people who are extreme know
the whole country what about this you
know you want a newspaper do you have
the money I mean it's literally this
kind of attitude is really heavy on
everybody wears it on their sleeve the
attitude so I wonder I'm like he's kind
of a creation of our own making in many
respects because the whole country
behaves like this now what I also detect
and I think the private polls that the
politicians have which are run by
companies that are what they call purple
they're kind of not red they're not blue
there they genuinely neutral they're all
showing that there's a massive backlash
but it's particularly female voters and
they don't care anymore about public
policy stances they care about having
someone their children can watch without
being embarrassed
it's literally like don't even talk to
me about public policy politics law
strategy I want a person that my child
can turn the television on and I don't
have to explain what they're saying you
know and I think that this is one of the
reasons we're seeing a record number of
female and minority political cannon
it's at every level of government and
they're starting to get voted in because
people don't care that they don't have
any experience ironically the same
motivation they had for electing Trump
which is I don't care if they have
experience I want this guy to take the
inside the government down from the
inside we have the exact same view just
now we went a different person to take
it down from the inside so the hostility
of the public towards the federal
government remains very very high and I
would argue it has been that way because
that was partly how Obama got elected
right he was elected on a radical change
mandate and a lot of people felt he
didn't deliver as much radical change as
they wanted so they went for something
even more radical in a sense they may do
the same again and by the way I'll
finish last thing is you know we have a
long tradition of electing very outside
candidates right nobody ever heard of
Bill Clinton two years before he became
president nobody heard of Obama two
years before Hylian present the
president I work for George WM just like
don't be ridiculous that's such an
outside possibility you'll never win any
wins so I would put a lot of money on
the person you never heard of right now
and would you say he's a good leader
Trump what he does cuz I mean if you
look at the figures economically well I
great but this is here's the question
how much is because of the president
right according to him well so every
president to be fair gets to claim
credit for the good stuff that happens
during their watch and then they all do
this you know in my last book you know I
wrote about how the economy was
absolutely improving and exports would
increase and foreign direct investment
increase and jobs were moving from China
back to the US that was the years before
Trump came to office so the real issue I
think is yes the economy is getting
better and that's a big problem in
politics because the Democrats now not
only don't have a candidate they don't
have a story the story used to be the
economies of the creeks you gotta vote
for me ya know what you're gonna say now
because the economy is not up the creek
and I think it's actually gonna keep
getting stronger
I'm think I'm the only bull left in the
entire financial markets cuz everybody's
like the crash is coming the crash is
coming tomorrow
[Music]
really genuinely prepared for a meltdown
on an epic scale and we're booming
therefore the bust is coming it has to
be because we've had and we've had the
longest bull run in history so that I
can't last and we've just seen fairly
recently
Amazon's valuation the first company had
a trillion dollar valuation so most
people think that's it where we're at
the top I have the opposite view I think
the Amazon hitting a trillion is the
beginning of a whole new era of
valuations that we're in a whole new
category and that's partly because we
still have twenty trillion dollars from
quantitative easing left in the system
that now is coming off the sidelines
because investors are going wait a
minute inflation is definitely picking
up then we can see that now in the data
it's no longer that you know every time
you go out for dinner you're like what
the steak costs what do you know the
wine costs more I mean everyone palpably
knows prices are higher but the data is
now really reflecting that it's higher
so investors know you lose money every
day that you have inflation if you have
cash so they're going I got to get out
of cash so what are they gonna get into
if you have inflation your honor about
bonds so you're gonna buy equities what
they call private equity which means
private investment in private businesses
or hard assets like infrastructure and
and all of those guess what they do they
make the markets go higher so I actually
think that that we should be preparing
for several more years of stronger
performance rather than a sudden crash
so he's gonna get reelected well no not
necessarily because you can have the
economy performing well and have so
turned off the public even in your own
team that everybody goes basta enough
isn't in history of American elections I
I haven't gone back and down the numbers
but I would say would be it would be
hugely exceptional to have a strong
economy and get sucked out right but if
you're hugely obnoxious you know
well it's just like your former boss is
a good example I mean the Iraq war was
deeply unpopular same in in Britain too
Tony Blair was deeply unpopular for
going into Iraq but they both got
reelected because the economy was doing
well right it did and so the question is
is is that decision about Iraq
less offensive to people than what Trump
has done done on the side in a way yeah
interestingly maybe and what does that
say about all of us right and our
interest in people affected by our own
decisions
these are just crazy to consider put it
that way that is pretty crazy I mean you
know the war in Iraq killed
Milly's a million people hi I know I saw
something that's questioning the other
thing is it's very awkward you know a
lot of Republicans like myself we wanted
someone who was gonna you know push the
establishment shake it up a bit
make government smaller reduce taxes
hopefully rein in the spending you know
we we like this as libertarians but what
we weren't really banking on with
someone who would do it in such a way as
to create enemies at every turn and send
messages to the public that unless
you're in my particular category or a
second-class citizen this is totally
inconsistent with these core values that
you're trying to promote individual
freedoms versus centralized government
so now there's this awful situation that
you had a lot of Republicans are like I
like the philosophy but I can't handle
the delivery and I think this again is
gonna be really hard because now what
I'm arguing is that we're gonna have
we're gonna see a Republican go up
against the president and that is a very
unusual thing it's it I'm sure it has
but it has but but it's usually a dead
end
but on this occasion maybe not maybe not
and then I only got into the whole
business of the real possibility that
Trump doesn't run he voluntarily doesn't
run he announces I'm gonna step down but
he'll never say step down what I'll say
is I have bigger plans
and my bigger plan is I am going to
launch what they're calling tienen it's
the Trump version of CNN it is the Trump
platform that will have everything from
reality TV to political talk shows I
mean literally it'll be tienen and my
guess is if that's where he wants to go
I think he does want to go there I think
was planning for that when he ran for
the presidency and expect to win he
expected to use that to launch this
thing but I think he's probably already
raised a good chunk of change to do that
and wouldn't have a hard time raising
money to do it if he leaves and actually
the politicians on the left and the
right might say you know what that would
be an excellent solution because then
nobody has to pull the trigger on an
impeachment we bargain with them that if
he goes we don't prosecute him the New
York State Attorney General vaguely says
yeah and then as soon as he's out begins
prosecution because they're not going to
hold back they're gonna go for what they
go for but at least then the fight is
private it's not a public fight of the
president in the Oval Office it's a
private fight of a former president
about his businesses and Donald if you
watch but but to be fair the tienen
think don't forget there's a huge
component of the American public who do
think in this way and will like what
he's doing no one should know and you
can see that this has popularity
approval you know it gives remains like
48 48 percent 48 percent no matter what
happens and so it can't be too
dismissive of that side they are real
and they're not going to go away
[Music]
let's move on to technology you've got a
whole chapter in your book which talks
about that and like I said last time we
were absolutely fascinated by and you
know what I was thinking
you and I met two years ago at coconut
mix in Ireland doing a comedy and we
were chatting in the bar after one of
the shows that we were on and you were
telling me about this new thing in China
where they're gonna have the system
where they're gonna track everybody's
behavior and all this stuff and I'll be
honestly pepper I really like you but I
was sitting there listening to you going
she's a little bit crazy she could be a
little bit crazy
maybe she smoked a lot of weed when she
was yes yeah
so interesting yeah I was sitting that
and then a year later boom it's happened
it's real and that's what you were
talking to us about last time you were
on the show what the hell is going on
and what's to come because now I believe
you thank you okay so let's just quickly
go through what is already real right
if you J walk in not all of China
they've only rolled it out in one city
but they're gonna roll it out nationally
a few jaywalk it clocks that you've done
it because the cameras are ubiquitous
now so the facial recognition is
incredibly strong they have the most
valuable artificial intelligence startup
in the world in fact the most valuable
startup in the world called cents time
and it can recognize an individual out
of a crowd of 10,000 and it can
recognize your emotional state at any
given time so it clocks it's you and
particularly you next thing you know you
picked your mobile phone up and the fine
for having jaywalked is already in your
text messages if not already deducted
from your bank account and your name and
or your government number is already
broadcast on the OLED screen that's
above the intersection the nearest
intersection so you've now been
broadcast to everyone nearby that you
are bad and you just violated the law
now this is important because what it
does it affects your effectively
personal uber score they're the social
credit system is based on the idea that
you're given a score and
reflects your social compliance so if
you google stuff that they don't want
you looking at your score goes down if
your brother or your sister does it your
score goes down right because Mao always
said the the best eyes and Watchers it's
not the government it's to get a better
report on each other and this is the
kind of us I mean the Stasi would love
the system but it's bigger than that
within the last few weeks it's been
announced that when you tap swipe and
pinch on your mobile device it's a
better indicator of who you are than
your thumbprint so now even if you're
using someone else's phone they know
it's you triangulate that with the way
you walk it turns out your walking gait
is also a better indicator of who you
are then your thumbprint so what they're
doing is taking all these things and
triangulating think about it as
previously independent silos of data
now they triangulate using artificial
intelligence to pull it all together but
it goes even deeper than that
and recently they arrested someone at a
rock concert of like 60,000 people
because again the face went by one
camera banging at clock's this is person
as wanted and they went to the person's
seat can you know the debit card
yep the ticket that they're arrested I
think they now have 11 million people
who are you can buy a train ticket or a
plane ticket but you can't board it they
won't permit you so effectively you
wherever you are no so they're putting
you into digital digital prisons so I
think one of the spouses of one of the
dissenters she's like blocked into a
very small few block area around her
house and any time she tries to move
beyond it the officials are alerted and
a police will be right there
so she's literally stuck in it in a
digital prison this is basically what
the technology permits and it rewards
you if you do things that are supportive
of what government said shouldn't it
basically penalizes you if you don't
we're doing the same thing in the West
it's just it's not government that's
doing it we have
private entities that do it we have
Facebook the desert we have Amazon that
doesn't we have uber that does it
and I don't know if you saw but there's
been an announcement that there's been a
deal between it seems Google and
MasterCard so now if I go to you know I
don't know a department store and I buy
this color lipstick Google's gonna know
and now they know what they're gonna
advertise to me so I'm concerned about
this and I write a lot about this in my
book because imagine what we've got it's
a world where you were emitting data
points about yourself all the time
without even knowing it because you've
turned all the fitness apps off on your
phone but the fact is the way you walk
is revealing a lot about you including
by the way your your cardiac condition a
lot about your health is revealed by how
you walk so this multiplicity of data
points that you're throwing off but you
don't know who gets to see it
but whoever does get to see it they know
more about you than you know about
yourself and by the way it's a two-way
thing if I'm a chief executive and I go
on let's say this program and I start
talking about my company and I'm lying
this same facial recognition technology
can identify your micro facial movements
and they know that you're lying and they
can set the algorithms just short the
stock of your company as you're talking
on say CNBC's Squawk Box so think of it
as almost like a crystal ball of data
points and on the one side it will let
us conjure forth answers that will do
things like solve cancer literally we
will solve extraordinarily difficult
problems by having all this data but it
also changes the balance of power
between companies and customers because
companies will have so much information
that I've argued you know we used to
have insider trading laws we may need
insider trading laws that if I am
MasterCard now or Google my knowledge of
you is so great
forget Cambridge analytic ah they only
had five thousand data points on 81
million people and that was enough to
begin to influence your political
position I can tell you way more than a
political position if I have more than
that I can tell your refrigerator I can
say
anything I want so I think human beings
are very vulnerable to this kind of
power being exercised and similarly what
kind of world do we have if people don't
know how they appear and is there should
we have a right to know how do we look
with that data
slice looking at us at any given time so
in the book I've tried to lay this out
because we have a lot of leaders who are
making decisions about the landscape of
our future who don't understand what I
am saying and so they're there they're
literally missing a profound shift in
humanity well this is the future I mean
this is now it's not even the future
this is nothing I'm not telling you is
for the future it is already existing
right now
[Laughter]
jockeying aside but then that literally
means if you were being attractive every
single second of every day if they're
reading what you were doing if they can
manipulate you is that the end of free
will eventually this is just the this
we're so what's really intrigued to me
is when I was in college I studied
political philosophy and everyone went
oh my god you will never get a job
I mean you are permanently unemployed if
you say now we get to this and I'm like
these are questions of political
philosophy that's exactly what this is
this is about the balance of power
between states and citizens companies
and customers between citizens it's
about the the invasion of persons free
will absolutely these are all core
questions now they're they're not
tangential anymore and I and the more we
develop artificial intelligence the
greater than Abee for example I know a
guy who's building an extraordinary
company it is effectively gonna place
nano chips which are so small that that
they can fit inside the body they are at
the level or they're below the level of
atoms right you're basically in the your
ends of the level of you can see
someone's atomic structure they're nuke
DNA their cellular structure and their
organs because it's just they float
around in your body at the nano level so
that means the good news is when you get
cancer you get proteins in advance of
the cancer which now we don't detect
very well but and then you'll be able to
say you're building up proteins we see
it coming we can hit this thing and
you'll never get cancer but the bad news
is you're omitting information about
what is physically happening to you to
whoever has access to that data again
the good news is that will create a kind
of he calls it a cure chain the guy who
founded it Steve Papermaster like block
chain it's a cure chain will be able to
cure many obscure diseases that only a
few people have that right now are worth
fixing but with that you can fix it
easily but talk about privacy I mean the
health care companies will know more
about your health than you will ever
know about your own health so yes these
are really profound philosophical
questions well here's the thing is it's
not just health as well because we had
an evolutionary psychologist on the show
a few weeks back I don't know if you
caught that episode
Diana Fleischman and one of the things
she was talking about is genetic studies
the study of genetics is now coming to a
point where we can pretty confidently
say that there's a very strong genetic
component to behavior yes right so if
you can analyze people at that level and
their DNA and their genetics you're not
just going to be able to tell what
disease they might develop or whatever
you're gonna be able to tell what their
personality type is to some extent what
their choices are gonna be what their
political leanings are gonna be exciting
really easy
[Music]
no you're good for three days I think
you guys are really missing them you
know what remember Minority Report and
that idea of pretty great cop pre-crime
yeah dad is already real in China they
are already using the artificial
intelligence in conjunction with this
extraordinary data sweep and they are
determining which people look more
inclined to cut corners than others and
then to start crowling them into a
corner and putting pressure to behave
better that's today that's not maybe
some day we already see this in motion
so there's again this is a huge
philosophical question as this question
of prejudging precognition premeditation
where did we draw these lines I ended up
going back and reading a book which
actually have to really strongly
recommend actually an author called
Norbert Weiner and a guy called Manuel
de Landa but Norbert Wiener who wrote a
book called the human use of human
beings and it's a profound book he wrote
in the late 1940s and he's the guy who
came up with this word cybernetics which
means the interface between humans and
machines so 1949 he's writing about how
we're gonna have this interface and even
assuming that machinery will begin to
enter our bodies which already it is but
that this will be this conversation
between humans and machines is going to
be central to our society it's so
beautifully written it's so clear it's
so absent of jargon or anything and it's
a wonderful baseline for anybody who's
very interested in this subject I would
say go back and read Norbert Wiener it's
very short he was considered the father
of modern artificial intelligence and
and that's where we got to go back to
start at the beginning
and you think he's the waywe movie I
know it's a very broad question but do
you think it's you is positive on the
whole or do you think this is actually
quite worrying and what we're heading to
a dystopia I am very positive my leaning
is
I think that all this innovation
artificial intelligence automation and
robotics are fundamentally going to
solve many more problems than they
create but the problems they create are
very serious so it's a bit like cars you
know I think cars are marvelous and can
they kill thousands of people every year
yes they can so you know you wouldn't
we don't say okay anybody can invent any
kind of car they want and just put it on
the road no we have rules of the road
right we have manufacturing standards we
have health and safety and we've gotten
better at it right when I was a kid they
just dates me but you know we didn't
even then we'd have seatbelts so we can
have our bags you know the seats weren't
even fixed they used to just flop back
and forth we just thought that was
normal you know so now we have airbags
and seatbelts that's a very good thing
we're gonna have airbags and seatbelts
for the robotic era too for sure but so
I definitely lean on the side that this
is hugely beneficial to society and I
think it's massively democratizing
because it's putting power in the hands
of people who haven't had it before and
everybody always argues man says well
you gotta have a PhD from Stanford or
Berkeley in order to even play in this
game and I say no that's not true any
longer
I was recently at a really cool event
held by the founders forum called
accelerate her and it was about
promoting women in robotics and business
and anyway fascinating woman there who
had was into fashion fashion blogging
but never was able to make any money out
of it and she creates she basically just
used apps that you create on your phone
and created an app that lets fashion
bloggers all over the world actually
sell the product they're writing about
through their app so they get a little
piece they get to take I don't know
whatever 10% 5% suddenly you've got
women all over the world that tend to be
women the women who are making half a
million bucks a year from their
Instagram account just playing on it
because the technology has empowered
this so it's not the story that the the
insiders have a lock on this anymore
it's becoming ubiquitous and I think
that's a super beneficial thing
to society so then it's a race between
the citizen and the state who's got that
information and how is it permitted to
be used my concern would be the recent
stuff that we've seen the Frances like
Facebook and Twitter
you know they've not come out well of
recent news stories about them and you
look at you know Donald Trump got
laughed out when he said that Twitter
and Facebook is biased or whatever but
actually then Twitter came out said yes
yes we are we are and we're going to
just shut down the accounts of those
people that we don't like yes which
they're doing well oh yeah so this
raises to me really interesting question
about why is it we only have one
Facebook what why don't we have more
competition we why do we have its
monopoly positions in these social media
arenas it's very interesting I'm not
sure I have an answer as to why well
their currency is the ubiquity isn't it
like everyone is on it that's what makes
it why is it that you a few of them and
and they'll serve kind of very different
purposes so they tend to have monopolies
over the space that they're in
where are the competitors this is super
interesting to me why it's harder to
create competition in this tech space
than it is if it's a grocery store on
the corner but seems to be but I do
think all of these things for me
it changes the landscape of leadership
and I by that I'm speaking very broadly
I don't just mean political leaders and
business leaders even religious and
community leaders I don't mean all of us
have to kind of think about what is the
same and what's changed and so what I've
argued here with my co-author Chris
Lewis is some things have profoundly
changed so one of them is we used to in
the 20th century the answer was always
in drilling down into greater
quantitative detail because somewhere in
there there'd be some a black box and
that's where your answer was actually
that didn't really work out so well and
the financial crisis I would say arose
in large part because of this approach
now in the 21st century okay you can
drill down a few one but the answer
resides in the look across not the
analytical thinking but the
parenthetical thinking this connecting
the dots between the silos seeing the
whole landscape or
another way of putting it is we used to
be all about measuring the math what are
the numbers give me the data points now
it's equally important or maybe more so
to understand the mood that that the
facts and the feelings are very
different things and I know we'll get a
lot of pushback because people say well
you can't analyze feelings and I'm like
well I'm sorry you can when you get
voted in or out of office and you feel
it when your customers turn on you for
no reason that you can quantify but
everybody knows so it's about using not
only your head but all the parts your
left brain and your right brain and
really joined up thinking and also
including in your thought process what's
the heart aspect because that's the part
when I talk about technology it's not
your intellect the twist so much like
for your heart because you're like for
what happens to individuals what happens
to people right that's your heart
speaking and so the book is very much
about we need a lot more heart in our
leadership we need a lot more joined up
thinking and also I know this sounds
really corny but leadership in the 20th
century was all about the leader it was
the cult of the leader it was the Jag
world you know it was one infallible
leader kind of the Jesus Christ model of
Management now it's about the ship it's
about the team it's about the
organization that's about bottom up not
top down and a lot of our leaders today
have no idea how to manage in that
environment they don't think inclusively
so if there's anything the core message
of the book is we need much more
diversity of thinking and diversity of
people is critical to that and I'm
hugely supportive that we have much much
more diversity people and I don't just
mean gender although that's a big push
in the book but I mean ethnicity income
background neuroplasticity how your
brain is wired up I mean really a
diversity of experience but you can
still have a room full of people who all
look very different who go Trump will
never win then you have a problem so one
other things leaders need to do is to
stop focusing on prediction because if
you say Trump will never happen that's a
prediction and instead get focused on
preparedness
for things that sound way out there and
and use scenarios to test your
robustness in your your agility I was
just gonna say if we just move on a
little bit to virtual reality um I was
at a comedy club playing this comedy
club and one of the guys working there
is of a graduate and he was saying that
actually in a few years time comedy
clubs will become obsolete but you know
bars will be coming up well obsolete and
that this will all go into the virtual
environment can you see is that a
reality or do you think people will
always need to be sitting in a room
together and having that emotional and
physical connection buckle your seat
belt because I work in this space
because with my robotics company you
know we're making drones commercial
drones one of the ways we deliver the
information is through virtual reality
so our clients can put on goggles and
then walk through an asset that's on the
other side of the world so if you had an
avalanche the mining site suddenly you
could be inside that mining site and
viscerally feel it as opposed to
watching a video in a two dimension so I
spent a lot of time in this space and it
is so realistic the brain cannot
distinguish between real and virtual I
recently did a new virtual reality game
it was like in a big warehouse and I
know I'm standing on a flat floor in a
big warehouse and there's nothing to
bump into and yet at one point I am like
on the hundred and fifty seventh floor
of a building that has been blown out by
explosives and I have to cross a rickety
bridge and I'm literally like don't be
an idiot
it's a floor you're in a building but
your brain is going can you might fall
you might fall it is so realistic and
now the real kicker we're starting to
get haptics and this is what's a word
everybody should look up and no haptics
are items of clothing that permit
feeling from a remote location
so haptic gloves people are familiar
with haptic gloves so you can grab
things in a in a video game by going
like this but now we're getting
full-body haptics
let's say I go on a virtual reality
boxing program when the guy in Tokyo
who's playing a game at midnight and I'm
sitting here in London well we go
against each other in that boxing ring
and he hits me in the solar plexus I'm
gonna feel that because the haptic thing
that I'm wearing is gonna give me that
punch now I may be able to choose that I
only want to feel 1/10 of what he's
throwing right I could do that but it'll
all be scored yeah and because the
Internet is a scoring mechanism which is
actually one of my political philosophy
questions is do we want to live in a
world where we're all being scored all
the time because we're is there any
place for you know beauty I mean how do
you smile you guys they do score beauty
which I just find incredible you know
the women one out of ten like you know
what I mean though beauty is not a thing
that can happen on a numerical scale and
so this business of moving into a world
where everything is scored and then
marry that up with haptics and virtual
reality you're gonna have people are
gonna go I got a full force I don't know
if you saw this bill Berg film ready
player one
it is super worth watching it is our
first time that we really are shown what
living in a virtual reality world is
going to look and feel like and at one
point the main character is in this
situation and he and and his friends say
turn it down so you don't feel the full
blow and he goes no I'm a real guy and
so he sets his outfit to feel whatever
the other player is throwing at him the
point is people are gonna get hurt and
put in another way the Germans recently
developed really interesting virtual
reality chair basically sits on bungee
ropes that are attached to the sides of
the room so that when you sit in the
chair with your goggles on not only will
you see the VR world but you're gonna
feel the actual g-forces now you will be
moving and I took one look at that and I
went that chair someone's gonna have a
heart attack in that chair because the
brain can't tell the difference they're
gonna step off the edge of the building
in the VR and then the chair is gonna go
wolf and that guy is gonna have a heart
attack it's like
matrix the matrix your mind makes the
real and then in fact I would have even
been talking with them the Red Cross
about torture and the need to have a new
Geneva Convention on torture because if
if I am given these VR goggles and and
I'm a victim of torture well if what I
see is that someone's just cut my hand
off my brain is going to process as if
that injury is real you won't be able to
and if you touch me when that when that
happens on my screen yeah my brain will
know something has happened they
visually see what's happened the brain
starts responding to that so I think
this waterboarding will have nothing on
what this can bring and equally even
things that seem innocent the fact that
this is what Spielberg shows in that
film ready player one that you can enter
alternative worlds and live there and
just stay there you don't ever have to
come back into reality and again a big
message we have in the book we looked at
all the research what's happening is
people are in theory more connected
because of the internet but in practice
there's less and less conversation less
and less human connectedness and virtual
reality and augmented reality take you
to an even greater level of
disconnectedness and create a world
where you think that certain things are
normal that are not at all normal in
real life because what's created in a
virtual reality world is it's comics
it's it's pictures and it's drawings but
they're so real that you start to
believe that's the standard that I want
that in my life but I do wonder I mean
with your question Francis right about
will people stopped coming to comedy
clubs or will comedy club stop exist I
mean right now you can pay 30 pounds or
whatever is for Netflix with even less a
month right and you can watch a Netflix
special from the best comedian in the
world whoever you think that is for that
amount or you can go to your local
comedy night and pay that same amount
twice a month right to go and see some
far inferior comedians by comparison in
person and they'll
lots of people I run a comedy club where
I live right people will come and do
that so do you think maybe we sometimes
we we kind of overestimate the the or
maybe underestimate people's desire to
be physically doing something physically
present with others physically connected
in a space that is without screens that
is without that thing where it's just
right you're right there in that moment
I think there's a market for both and I
think humans will be doing both but I
also think that it's not one or the
other like one thing that I'm working on
right now is being able to bring
augmented reality to the audiences that
I speak to when I do my public speaking
and you guys will be doing the same at
some stage you'll be able to say to the
audience if you pick your phone up and
point it at the stage I'm gonna show you
something and we're standing next to you
on the stage is suddenly gonna be a
Pokemon type thing that you've chosen an
example of something that's in your
comedy routine and now you guys are
creating an augmented reality experience
for that audience so it's not either/or
it's gonna merge more and more but also
it's a different level of risk watch if
I decide to come watch you guys live of
course this is extremely risky thing for
me to do by but there's a certain level
of risk that you might mess up or you
might surprise me because the mood in
that audience that night creates a
different energy level and you guys then
right because your routine changes
depending on the audience right versus
going to watch it on and that kind of VR
landscape might actually be it's more
like watching a pre-programmed thing so
the level of risk that it might screw up
is much lower our different so it
depends what your risk appetite is and
you'll measure that on any given day and
decide what's the right venue to express
that risk appetite but what I do think
is it's going to become so mainstream
that it'll reach the point we start
finding it hard to distinguish one from
the other in the same way that robotics
and automation will be increasingly
inside of us and it'd be hard to
distinguish between a person who is 100%
human and a person who's not we're kind
of already there as well
I mean it's also gonna impact on
people's mental health yeah big-time
because like you said you know you're
gonna go into these virtual reality
worlds where you know in a sense there
are no consequences for your actions you
can always you know get to the end of
the game start again whatever else and
then once you get into real life the
rules are completely different and when
it comes as well you know when things
between you know relationship sex all
the rest of it so in the book we talked
at some length about the fact that a
ever larger proportion and now it looks
like in some industrialized
industrialised countries it's heading
towards 15 percent of males under the
age of 25 have never had a relationship
because they live so much online or are
in a position where they can avoid the
human interaction that they do which
means they have no capacity to negotiate
with other human beings because you have
to learn that you have to learn how to
negotiate with other human beings we're
seeing record numbers of elderly people
oxygen to elderly let's say older people
people over the age of 40 but even
people over the age of 40 are not living
together any longer they're they're not
they may share a roof yeah but they
don't share a life they're not with a
partner they're in a rent share space
and those numbers are going up so the
real human consequences of all this
technology seems to be that it is
separating us from one another it's
ironic but that is what we're finding as
the result and this is a profound change
in the society we talk about it being
it's an atomization that the people
becoming more and more isolated and they
don't identify you know with with larger
groups they feel alone and isolated and
maybe that helps account for the rise of
identity politics is kind of it feeds
off of that sense of I'm alone I'm not
connected so how weird your uber
connected and simultaneously
disconnected and are there any remedies
to this on a personal level like like is
there something you do as a human being
to kind of plug yourself back into
reality in this yeah so yeah and isn't
it interesting that all the magnets in
Silicon Valley don't let their kids have
mobile devices
I mean how interesting yeah you know how
interesting I've heard so many of these
people who work on these tech products
say basically we're using all the
techniques you used to entice gamblers
yes that's what's your phone so yeah
maybe we need to learn how to turn stuff
off switch off actually have a
conversation and yes that is one of the
things that we recommend that taking it
the problem is people are so impatient
so they don't want to that that's just
painful for them they won't even wait
two seconds if a page doesn't load on
the web in two seconds they're gone so
one of the things we have to figure out
is how to cultivate patience there are
there are lots of these things but but
the societal impact is is quite profound
actually there's a there's a section if
I could be really boring there's one
page page 228 we made a list of all the
things that have profoundly changed so
this is about the whole landscape not
just technology technology feeds this
but it used to be we talked the good
used to be we the people now it's me the
people we used to like thoughtful clear
measured responses now it's Twitter at
speed its jargon it's emojis it's
compressed information we used to like
to study now it's all hacks and
shortcuts we used to like saving now we
like spending we used to dress up now we
dress down there's there's a whole swing
it's almost like you know when Alice and
wonderland drinks and she goes through
that looking-glass and she's ended up on
the other side of reality technology has
done this and I think we should be aware
of this list of what it's doing to us
which is you know much more profound
than just put your phone down a little
bit okay they yeah but we have to learn
how are we gonna deal with a world where
you know free speech has been replaced
by political correctness
these are super profound societal
changes and do you think these
technologies encouraging a narcissistic
behavior in people
sure absolutely it's the rise of the
selfie is only possible because of the
camera and and that sense is that's we
the people know me the people is a
person with the selfie stick and so yeah
technology that's part of being atomized
that we're not connected anymore it's me
and only me and why do I look there's a
question I've always wanted every to
whenever I speak to I can't believe I
forgot to ask that question you know
when you go on Google and you go know
what I need some new trainers and
Google's an advert for trainers comes up
are they really listening oh is that
slight paranoia well what we like I said
it's now in the public domain the Google
and MasterCard have a relationship and
and some kind of information sharing is
what's implied de basura I think what
Francis means is your phone
really picking up what you say and then
processing in that way well the answer
is it's perfectly capable of doing so
and many other internet things devices
in your home and in your life are doing
it as well so for example the you know
Amazon echo it's already been subpoenaed
in a murder trial as a witness and of
course the turkey oh yeah and by the way
it's a very good witness
it's a highly reliable witness well
absolutely because it's not the memory
any shape or form and I have to say the
story I love was the guy who thought he
was being really clever and left his
mobile phone at somebody else's house
drove to his house set the thing on fire
and then you know petrol gasoline
everywhere and thought he was in the
clear because he just wanted to get the
insurance money and he forgot he had a
pacemaker and the pacemaker was
broadcasting not only his location but
what was happening to his heartbeat as
he was setting a house on fire so this
thing is you are constantly emitting
data back to my point you may not even
know know how you're emitting it in
Sweden companies have recently
introduced microchipping the employees
in the thumb and amazingly a lot of the
employees in some of these companies are
like I'd love to do that because I don't
want to have to pay for my coffee
I just want to wave my hand and I'm done
it's like magic yes but guess what now
you're like on the grid and everything
you do is on the grid so the answer is
you should assume that any Internet of
Things device that is in your world is
perfectly capable of broadcasting not
only your voice but your physical
movement within the space vacuum
cleaners automated vacuum cleaners are
broadcasting the dimensions of the room
and the human use of that space it seems
in this family they come in to watch
television at 4:45 so if you want to
advertise spaghetti to these people four
o'clock might be a good time to hit that
little reminder for them so yeah this is
the point I mean again with social media
the bottom line is if you're not paying
for it you are the product this is why I
love to
in the show we talked about all kinds of
stuff on here about men and women
feminism everything but fundamentally
what I love is is when we do an
interview and I kind of go okay there's
some things I need to do differently in
my life you know like we had Diana
Fleischman on among other things she was
talking about veganism and she was
saying that actually it's very difficult
to be vegan
therefore the if you want to reduce the
quantity of suffering that you caused
and the number of deaths you've got to
start eating the biggest possible animal
does that make sense because there's
like a year's worth of me in a cow and
if you chicken you're gonna basically be
killing another creature every couple of
days so I pretty much don't eat chicken
now after that conversation now you know
beef and whales and whatever such a good
person comes hiya mate mate that's
that's me I'm workers help I'm so work I
can't sleep and that's why I love it but
this is like it's fascinating it's
terrifying I think it is absolutely
terrifying what you're talking about
it's also very encouraging that there's
going to be this ability to resolve all
these problems to fix the cancer or
whatever else but I mean I just think
we've got to be really careful I also
think you know there's an element there
there is a part of me that's going yeah
but we're still we still have that need
for personal contact we still there's
gonna be some kind of pushback against
all of this there's gonna be some kind
of feeling like you know what actually
no we want to get together we want to be
physically in the same like look at us
people will listen to an hour's
interview I mean we talk about you know
this kind of bite-sized everything is
now short attention spans but actually
there's a massive push back against that
now there are people we've went to meet
some people who do YouTube videos they
don't even show their face it's just a
guy talking for 40 minutes
yeah and Islam and he's not even like
doing kind of comedy like a little bit
of setup punchline he's just a guy
talking for 40 minutes people love their
you guys got a million subscribe and I
totally agree I think there's a market
for these things but but this idea that
we're automatically jumping to that end
I don't know one of the really tricky
parts of the book your guys are gonna
laugh we actually talked about one kind
of robotics and automation called
teledildonics
yes
and oh yes it's worse than you think
extending your penis remote Lisa
basically right yeah and so you know
people having sex using devices where
someone you've never met on the other
side of the world is controlling what
happens like we're moving both
directions simultaneously I know I'm
like oh my god I was amazed the
publisher let us put it in there but
it's a real phenomena like a real
phenomena the Elon Musk actually now
he's losing the pot but at any rate at
one point not so long ago he he said he
was in some kind of artificial
intelligence product that he'd been
introduced to and obviously is something
nobody else has seen yet and he
basically said this is a the thing I
experienced was something to do with
love not sex but love and so you don't
know is he talking about some kind of a
sex doll or is he talking about on an
interface with a computer I don't know
but what he said was it was so much
better than the real thing that it's
terrifying and it's going to be the end
of humanity and and I have to say this
is the thing we really have to think
about what are our basic human needs and
how do they get met you remember that
film with what keen Phoenix I think it
was where he falls in love with you
artificial intelligence who had Scarlett
Johansson's voice I think it was yeah
right but he literally begins to fall in
love because the AI knows the answers
and knows him so well and at the very
end is he's completely shocked to
someone who knows him so well can just
abandon him because you feel the
involvement and so again we're back to
political philosophy how do how do we
handle this because we're vulnerable
human beings are vulnerable so the sex
realm I mean it's quite there's this is
what Donna Fleischman told us there's
quite a big difference between men and
women in terms of kind of sexual
preferences yeah that's sexist I know
but
she's talking about the fact that men
basically they have less disgust when it
comes to the sexual domain so that means
men as we all know tend to be more
adventurous and more kind of right so if
you're a man in this new brave new world
and there's stuff that you want to do
sexually right why would I why would I
me a real woman and have to like
negotiate you know right but not even
dinner but like I can do what I want as
opposed to what we both agreed to do
right and all this other stuff and yeah
why would you meet a real woman in that
situation right I mean theoretically at
least that's kind of where this is
headed no I I and although this seems
like a narrow thing were sidelining into
this is so fundamental to say the human
condition there's a there's a writer who
I think is really interesting like a
California guru called David data and he
writes about he writes about sex and
what makes sex really good and he says
there are really three kinds of
relationships there's the one where one
person is saying I want Ben that's what
you've just described I want and they're
all about imposing what they want they
just need another person to do it
then there's the I want but I know you
do too so let's negotiate right
and it's transactional even if it's
elegantly transactional it's still I'll
take your dinner if you know but the
love love is I choose to love and it's
unconditional and and my interest in
loving you is for your individuation as
a human being you know that's how do we
get more of that when we're in this
environment that's a really interesting
question and but in this book we kind of
we dance a little around but we kind of
say really good leadership has love and
now that just sounds so corny has to be
ridiculous but in the context of what
we're saying you begin to understand
love the care for the well-being of
other human beings now is a fundamental
issue for all of us we have to think
about what's happening to people with a
heartfelt perspective
doesn't it also come down to
gratification and instant gratification
because if you go into a computer game
you can be a black belt martial artists
in four different disciplines just by
switching it on but the reality is in
life if you want to be that that takes
what 15 20 years constant discipline
eating right and the same with love love
is incredibly hard it means going
meeting lots of different people
involves rejection and then you know it
involves compromise maybe it's because
it's [ __ ] hard well and not only that
but again virtual reality world it's
really interesting because now there
been computer games where you have
people who are winning who don't fit
what that model is you could have a 50
year old african-american woman emerges
as the champion in a virtual reality
world where in a physical world
she wouldn't win that fight but she can
win it online so so an in virtual
reality and the other thing is you know
about the marshmallow test no no so I
think it was Harvard University of Bath
can't remember but anyway the
marshmallow test was they took little
kids five six years old and said and
left them alone in a room and said if
you don't touch yes the marshmallow will
give you three yeah and they left him
for 20 minutes and the ones who weren't
able to wait 20 minutes and ate the
marshmallow versus the ones who waited
the ones who waited had much better
human skills in the easier life they
higher achievement levels the people who
can't wait their achievement levels are
not good
their empathy and capacity for
connections not good
we need better performance on a
marshmallow test as a race humanity
needs to do better at the marshmallow
test and the problem is all this
technology is pushing us in the other
direction
so how do we make choices that
balance it out because otherwise we may
end up in a yeah you said is a dystopian
we could end up in a dystopian place but
I don't see that we have to but we could
well on the subject of impatience time
I'm afraid is up so coming back as
always to our final question what is
something that we're not talking about
we've talked about all kinds of
interesting things today what is
something that we are not talking about
that we ought to be talking about oh
well
gosh so I should ask me at this
beginning because then I would've
thought about I don't know what I still
think all of the stuff we've talked
about just now we're not talking about
we're not talking I think look in my
world in financial markets and stuff
really everybody is just preparing for
catastrophe all the time and I don't
think we're talking enough about what
about if all of this technology all this
stuff works and we end up in a world
where we can solve the any food
shortages I already know technology that
can do this so I think we're there how
do we deal in the world that doesn't
have any scarcity it has ubiquity that's
a really interesting question and I
think we're moving towards our ubiquity
world more than a scarcity world but
with all the problems that we've talked
about so to me that's the interesting
thing we're not talking about a
ubiquitous world not a scarce one all
right well if you've still not left the
internet after that destroyed all your
mobile devices in one big house fire
follow a paper dr. Pippa mag and Grenn
on twitter at dr. Pippa em buy her book
the leadership lab which is coming out
on October 4th 28th of October in the US
get the book is going to be fantastic
and as always follow us at trigger pod
on Twitter on Instagram on Facebook
obviously subscribe to this YouTube
channel if you're watching it and click
that Bell button right next to subscribe
button which make sure that you get the
videos as they come out and you get
notified anything else Francis yeah
don't smoke weed whilst you're watching
this episode
you know I feel like I need to smoke
some weed just to calm down lots of the
mind blowing oh yeah yeah it's been so
great to have you thank you so much for
coming on yeah it's been an absolute
pleasure prettier alright see you next
week guys thank you but
[Music]